Yarn color for each finger.
Council members in attendance council member abby cayman
district c council member carolyn evan shabaz district d council
member tiffany d. Thomas district f vice
chair ed pollard district j Council Member Michael
Kubosh at large position three council member staff from Council
Member Leticia Plumber's office, staff from Council Member Mike
Knox's office and staff from Council Member Mary
NAN Huffman's office. All budget workshops will be conducted
in person. Only public speakers have the option to come in in person or
virtually 48 hours prior to the start of all workshops.
Presentation materials are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered
to each council office. Our departments have been directed to
provide written responses within 48 hours of the
conclusion of their presentation to any questions posted by council
members to SharePoint. The budget workshop schedule is posted
on the BFA website. Questions from council members
can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop process,
the earlier the better, allowing the departments plenty of time to
provide responses. All public speakers should be signed up
to speak. If you have not signed up, please sign up at the front
table. My staff, Carolina, will be monitoring the
public speakers list. The 2023 budget amendment
template has also been uploaded to SharePoint. Mayor Turner sent
out a memo to all council members and council offices to ensure a
productive discussion on the 23 proposed budget.
Amendments are due Wednesday, May 25.
Again, amendments to the budget are due Wednesday, May 25.
The agenda. Today we'll hear from Public Works,
Department of Neighborhoods, It, Human Resources,
Office of Business Opportunity, Fleet Management,
Housing Department and Houston Public Libraries. As a reminder,
only people attend in virtual or public speakers. There are six virtual
speakers signed up for public comment to speak, and there are 13 people
virtually joining us. And we'll get their questions after the presentations
and questions from council members have been concluded. I would like
to welcome council member Sally Alcorn at large
position five, and staff from Carlos Cisnero's
office, council District H. At this time, I'd like
to welcome Director Carol Haddock and Mr. Samir Salanki
and to provide the public Works department's update And
Happy Public Works Week. All right,
thank you very much. Good morning, everybody.
Today we're here to discuss the fiscal year 2023 budget
for Houston Public Works. My name is Carol Haddock, director of Houston Public
Works. And I'm joined by my colleague, Samir Solanki, chief financial officer for
Houston Public Works. We have other members of the Houston
Public Works executive team and also our budget team that have joined
us in this meeting so that we may answer questions on the spot if you
may have them. Next slide, please. Oh, wait,
you're already at the next slide. Houston Public Works
aims to abide by our purpose and our five to thrive values in all that
we do. Together, we create a strong foundation for Houston to
thrive, and we do this every day by doing the things that most people
don't see or notice unless something goes wrong. And we
take great pride in that. We embody our five to thrive values every
day. We operate through integrity, through teamwork.
We take ownership of things we're responsible for. We strive
to communicate and we look for respect,
starting with ourselves, our colleagues, the citizens we serve,
this body and ultimately the city of Houston itself. Next slide,
please. Houston Public Works Executive
Teams consists of the capable people that you see on this slide.
At the end of this presentation, there is a very extensive appendix.
It shows all of our accomplishments for fiscal year 2022,
even though it's not over yet. And while I would love to talk
about our accomplishments, I am going to skip that today and leave that for
you to look at at the back of the presentation. So please
do take the time to look through that as you go through it.
Next slides, please, for what you see on a
day to day basis. Our operational service lines, our five
service lines that provide the services. Our capital projects,
customer account services, houston Permitting Center, houston Water
and Transportation and Drainage operations. These service lines don't
have a single cost fund center. They actually have multiple
funds, and most of them have multiple cost centers.
We have a long presentation and I am going to hand this over to
Samir Solanki to discuss the budget for Houston Public Works at this time.
Samir? Thank you, Carol. Next slide, please.
Like Carol mentioned, this is a pretty significant presentation.
We'll do our best to try to get through all the information in the time
that's allotted. Like Carol had mentioned,
public Works consists of several funds and this slide summarizes the changes in
revenues and expenditures from fiscal year 2022 for each
of these funds. I'm not going to call out each of these numbers as we'll
cover all of this in detail in the upcoming slides. Please keep in mind
that the variances are from the FY 22 current budget.
And because this is rolled slide, these numbers are in millions.
Once we get to each of the fund, we'll be talking in thousands. Next slide,
please. First, we'll begin by
discussing the General Fund. Okay,
there we go. Now, this is just an overview of the major services requirements,
impact and population served by the General Fund within the Houston
Public Works Department. Let's dig a little deeper. The requirements
for this service delivery. Let me skip that part. Let's go to the
next slide.
There we go. These are the revenue overviews.
For the revenue portion, a small amount is brought in from recoveries and refunds,
and majority of this is from sale of capital assets.
Recoveries and refunds are from the recovery of electricity costs for
decorative lighting that's above the city standard.
Something like closer between poles or higher wattage bulbs,
which the city has paid to CenterPoint and bills back to the corresponding management districts
who request the above standard lighting.
Next slide, please.
The majority of services for this portion of the General Fund is
related to electricity for traffic signals and street lights citywide,
which is considered a restricted account with no budgeted FTEs.
The Real Estate Management section generates revenue for the General Fund
by selling property and easements throughout the Houston area, and this
is accomplished by nine positions within this fund. This section
is also responsible for management of Houston Public Works real estate inventory,
including oversight and management of city owned property interest such
as streets, easements, alleys and fee owned land and the process
requests for encroachment into streets or alleys through the Joint Referral
Committee process, the JRC process.
Next slide, please.
Now we'll take a look at the expenditures and this is a further breakdown of
these expenditures for the General Fund. The General Fund's largest expense
consists of the restricted accounts that I'd mentioned previously, which include
service chargebacks for fuels, electricity, It accounts
and other items. The projected budget for electricity in
this fund is 21.4 million due to transitioning
from a floating rate to a locked in electricity rate.
Next slide, please.
Now, this chart is broken out by personnel
and nonpersonal items, and you'll notice that the largest amount is
made up of restricted accounts, that is primarily electricity,
which is at 21.4 million, and the It hits restricted
accounts for about 300,000.
Next slide, please.
The Net Change slide walks through the items that contribute to
the increase in expenditures for the Houston Public Works portion of
the General Fund. The operating budget decreased slightly in
supplies based on spending trends as compared to fiscal year 22.
There were increases in contractual or mandated adjustments for restricted accounts
and interference services of about 700,000,
as well as 17,000 increase in hope and benefit rates,
which resulted in an overall increase of 3.3% in
the fiscal year 2023 budget. Next slide,
please. Now let's move on to
the project cost recovery fund.
This slide provides an overview of the major services, requirements, impacts and
populations served by the Project Cost Recovery Fund.
This is a revolving fund and it derives its revenues from different funds within
Houston Public Works, which means that whatever revenues are brought in
must be fully expended.
Next slide. Got it. The Project Cost Recovery Fund
revenues are increasing from 51.9 million to 55.7
million, for about a difference of 3.8 million.
The project cost recovery fund expenses are increasing. Excuse me.
2.8 million of this is due to increase in hope and benefits,
and the remaining increases are in restricted accounts, interfund services
and building maintenance. Next slide,
please.
And this is a program organizational chart which I'll go through individually.
The transportation and drainage Operations manages and analyzes
traffic calming patterns, collects data coordinates with regional partners
to develop transportation and drainage projects.
The office of the Director administers the city's MWD
program. Then we have Houston Water, which manages contractual issues
and other required coordination related to the Northeast water
purification plant expansion. Then we have Financial Management
Services that processes the pay estimates and project reimbursements,
provides financial reports on project and grant related activities,
monitors and accounts for CIP related revenues and expenses.
Then we have Capital Projects, which is responsible for the implementation
of engineering and construction of infrastructure projects for the City's
adopted five year CIP plan. Then there's
also Information Technology, which provides and maintains technology
solutions to support planning, design, construction,
operation and maintenance of the public infrastructure systems,
and also technically assists the Houston Public Work inspectors to
perform work and input data into Cipms from remote
sites. Then the managed support. Finally, the Managed and Support Branch provides
necessary funding to ensure effective delivery of accurate, reliable and
timely biweekly payroll reports. Next slide please.
And this chart shows a breakdown between the personnel
and non personnel. The total budget proposed is 55.7
million. Of that, the personal accounts for 45 million.
Next slide please.
Now we move on to the building inspection fund, which is also
the Houston Permitting Center.
The major services is to ensure buildings and structures
adhere to City of Houston's Building Code, as well as review and approve
commercial and residential development plans for the City's infrastructure.
The impact is safety, usability and sustainability of
the private and publicly built environment. Next slide,
please. The Building
Inspection Fund of revenues are increasing from 84.4 million
up to 91.0 million for a 6.7 million
increase due to more anticipated permitting and construction activity
and annual CPI increase in fees.
The expenditures are decreasing from 103,000,000 to 102.5
million, mainly due to reduction in the fiscal 23
for the design and development of the new permitting and inspection
system and decreasing in land and building costs for joint parking
garage with HPD. And this is offset by the increase
in personal costs and restricted budgets.
Next slide please.
And this is the program organizational chart for the Building Inspection
Fund and for the Office of the Director. We have the Mayor's Office for
people with Disabilities, serves as the primary advocate for
the rights and needs of citizens with disabilities, serves as a liaison
between the Mayor, City Council, city Departments and other public and private entities.
Then the Houston Permitting Center, which performs a regulatory role to ensure the safety,
usability and sustainability of private and public
built environment. Then also the practical application of reviews,
permanent permit administration and field inspection for building codes,
sign administration and public infrastructure. Then we have
Information Technology that provides the highest quality technology based
services in the most effective and cost effective manner.
Then we have the Management Support Branch, which provides necessary funding
for the Building Inspection biweekly payroll function.
Next slide, please.
The total proposed budget is 102.5 million. Of that,
personnel accounts for around 70.8 million. The nonpersonal
budget is around 31.6 million. 5.4 million
is for the Hue permit system, 5.9 million is for the HPC
support and 4.3 is for HPC, It and supplies and
services. Restricted accounts consist mainly of hits restricted accounts,
which is 2.7 million. Houston Public Works indirect costs
of 2.3 million, citywide indirect costs of 1.6
million. Fleet restricted accounts, which is 1 million and payroll restricted
accounts of about 1 million. Then the building code enforcement of
3.1 million is broken down into 1.5 million of consulting
services to assist the city in residential and commercial brand review
and inspection in citywide developments, with the remaining 2.3
million going towards vehicles and other services.
Next slide, please.
Let's keep going. Transportation and Drainage something got off here.
All right. Transportation and Drainage, which contains funds 23
223, 1020, 311 and 20 312.
Funds 23 1020 311 and 20 312 comprise
of the Build Houston Forward Program. These funds were
previously all held in 23 ten and were split into
three funds in fiscal year 2021.
Pause for just a moment. The presentation appears to have disappeared from the
screens.
We have an It issue, as you recognize, so please follow along on
your printed copies if you have them at your disposal. Okay,
thanks. 24. Okay, we're on slide number
24. The major services provided
are to maintain and operate street and drainage systems,
to plan for reinvestment of infrastructure and growth needs for the
City of Houston, and to coordinate with outside entities for impacts to
city infrastructure and uses. The impacts affect neighborhood
drainage, subregional or drainage, and detention and citywide
mobility. Next slide.
This is the overview of the revenues for the transportation and drainage operations.
The Stormwater Fund, which is 23 two revenues are decreasing by
3.3 million, and this is due to about 5.8 million
less transfer needed from the combined utility system to cover
operations and maintenance. And this is offset by an increase in transfer from
the drainage charge from Fund 23 ten by 2 million.
Fund 23 ten. Revenues are increasing by
400,000 due to higher projected amount of interest earned
compared to fiscal year 22.
The Advalorum Tax Fund 20 311 revenues
are increasing by 2.1 million, mainly due to 1.7
million additional tax revenues projected to transfer
in from the General Fund, as well as 400,000 higher projected amount
of interest earned compared to fiscal year 2022.
The Metro Etol Fund 20 312 is mostly flat,
increasing mainly due to 550,000 increase
in Interfront revenues for potential work performed by transportation
and drainage operations for other Houston Public Service Lines or other city departments,
as well as 315,000 for expected reimbursements
under the Metro General Mobility Program.
Next slide, please.
And this is the transportation and drainage expenditures. On the
expenditure side, the Stormwater Fund is decreasing by 1.5 million
due to lower operating costs, which is about 2,000,002.6 million,
restricted budgets of about 300,000 and capital rollovers
of 600,000. This is offset by an increase in personnel
costs of about 2 million. The Ddsrf
Funds group are increasing by 6.2 million due
to a 6.9 million increase in transfers to CIP,
which is offset by a 500,000 decrease in supplies.
Keeping in mind that 22 to 23 1020 311 20
312 make up the Ddsr Funds group. Next slide.
Where are we? There we go.
We are on slide number 27, Stormwater Fund 23
two, the program organizational chart,
the transportation and drainage operations responsible for
inspecting, cleaning and repairing current storm sewer infrastructure.
The Financial Management Services manages payment of the principal and interest
on stormwater debt and pension obligation bond debt.
The Houston Permitting Center maintains and administers the city's Texas Pollution Discharge
Elimination System. The TPDES Stormwater Permit Information
Technology provides the highest quality technology based service in the
most effective and cost effective manner. And then Management Support Branch
provides training related to various safety practices, safety awareness
initiatives, and acts as a liaison between Division and
certain state and local agencies. Next slide,
please.
Man that's 28.
Yeah, 28. I think I just went through Tammy. There was yep.
Then the Ddsrf drainage charge fund 23 ten.
The office of this is again the program organizational charge. Slide 28.
We have the Chief Recovery Office liaisons with governments and other
organizations to reduce flooding risk. Mission is to ensure a
rapid quality recovery from Hurricane Harvey and other disasters
and position the city to be less vulnerable to the next record breaking
storm. It also helps identify transformative projects and design
strategies for mitigating flood risk and achieving flood resiliency.
Then we have Financial Management Services, which manages funding
for various items such as transfer for Stormwater and the
Capital Improvement projects. Management Support Branch
provides necessary funding to ensure accurate, reliable and timely
biweekly payroll reports and then Customer Account Services,
which provides billing and customer service to drainage utility customers.
Next slide please. Slide 29.
The Ddsrf Advalorum Tax Fund 20 311,
which includes transportation and drainage operation, which is responsible for maintenance
of streets and bridges installation, operation and
maintenance of the traffic signal system. Installation of
maintenance of traffic control signs, pavement markings and flashing
school beacons maintenance of roadway lighting on major highways
conduct studies involving speed zones and traffic counts review of
street lined installations. Then the Financial Management Services branch
manages fund transfer for CIP projects and 380 agreements.
Next slide please. Slide 30. Ddsrf Metro
Etol program organizational chart of Which A
transportation and drainage operation is Responsible for maintenance of Streets and
bridges, installation operation, maintenance of the traffic signal
system, installation and Maintenance of the traffic control signs,
pavement markings and flashing School beacons. Maintenance of roadway lighting
for what I had just mentioned previously is also part of the 20 312
Information Technology. Provides help desk, desktop application work
management system support along With Other System Support.
The Management Support Services Branch provides necessary funding
to ensure effective delivery of professional services related to employee
health and safety response support in emergencies created
by natural or manmade disasters, spill response contract
compliance, accident and injury investigations and field surveys,
and inspections and also ensures accurate,
reliable and timely biweekly payroll reports.
Next slide please. Slide 31.
It looks like we're back. All right. The total purpose proposed budgets
is 390,000,000, of which personal accounts for
around 71.6 million and non personal accounts for around
318,000,000. The cash transfer is related to
capital projects expenditures account capital projects expenditures
account for a bulk of it and the remaining items are related to operations
and maintenance expense for street traffic and drainage related
items. Debt services is mostly comprised of retiring the
pre 2012 public Improvement bond debt in 23
two which the principal balance is about 18.8 million.
Next slide please.
Sure. The last part, the debt service is mostly comprised
of retiring the pre 2012 public
Improvement bond debt in 23 two which
the principal balance is about 18.8 billion. Next slide please.
We're on slide 32. Moving on to TranStar. Next slide.
There we go. TranStar is a collaborative
program between the city, Harris County, Metro and the
Texas Department of Transportation that provides transportation,
homeland security and emergency management for city and
13 surrounding counties. Next slide please. Slide 34.
On the revenue side, the decrease is due to the
reducing grant contributions from Metro. Metro reduced
contributions by 527,000 due
to Metro's takeover of the maintenance and upkeep of TranStar
Center from GSD. The increase in contribution from the
city of Houston and Harris County is about 76,000.
On the expenditure side, personnel and land and ground
maintenance services are the main drivers for the increase.
Then also the increase is also due to hope, pension,
health insurance and land and other ground maintenance costs.
Next slide please. Slide number 34 five.
Excuse me.
The Traffic Operations division which includes about
ten FTEs. That manages, operates and maintains a heat and transfer
system. Next slide please.
The proposed budget is 3.4 million of which nonpersonal
accounts for 2 million. The breakout is the
operations and maintenance accounts for 1.7 million which consists
of 575,000 for construction site work services
for about 400,000 for building maintenance,
150,000 for advertising, about 100,000 for
contingency and 400,000 for various other services and supplies.
The other remaining 373,000 belong to restricted accounts
which includes electricity, hits and then fleet,
payroll and utilities accounts. Next slide please.
Finally, we move on to
the biggest enterprise fund which is the combined utility system, the largest fund
group within Houston Public Works. The major
services for the utility are production and distribution of over 146,000,000,000
gallons of water, treatment of 90 billion gallons of wastewater and
billing and collection for 480,000 water
and wastewater accounts. Next slide please.
The revenue highlights include in fund 8300.
They're increasing mainly due to 280,000,000 water and sewer rate increase
adopted by council via ordinance 2021
five one five fund 83 one. There is a
5.7 million decrease in scheduled debt service payments then
fund 83 five is the combined utility system savings
account and doesn't typically generate revenue. However, in fiscal
year 2021 we had a $9.4 million
increase due to water authorities contribution for
the lease value payment which is about 9.4 or
9.5 million. Next slide please.
The expenditure highlights include the following for fund 8300,
there is an increase of 43.3 million increase in operations and
maintenance costs. And this is broken down into various
categories which include about 9.5 million in chemicals and gas,
3.3 million management consulting services,
1.1 miscellaneous support services, 8.1 million
in equipment services, 2.3 million in construction site
work services, 4.8 million in river authority contracts,
1.2 million in computer software,
2.8 million increases in the consent decrease stipulated penalties
4.2 million increase in building maintenance services, 2.1 million
increase in intrafund electricity maintenance, 1 million
Interfront application services, 1.8 million
in system debt service transfer, and 1 million in non
capital office expenditures. There's also a 19 million
increase in personnel due to hope and benefits rate changes
and a 2.3 decrease in debt service transfers.
For 83, one, there is a 5.8 million in
system debt services payment. Then for Fund 83 five,
we have an increase in the pay go, which is the pay as you
go service, the cash funding for the CIP portion. Then 11.7
million increase in capital equipment including new and rollovers,
4.7 million increase for meter replacement program
and 1.5 million increase for McKinney building maintenance and improvements
and 800,000 increase for Water Authority contract debt
and then a 4.8 million reduction in transfer to
Stormwater. Now, a quick note that we are purposely
making the decision to increase our cash funding or the pay go funding
for the combined utility system CIP so we can cash on projects instead
of debt financing given the current market environment that has high
inflation and also with the rising interest rates. Next slide,
please. This is the
program organizational chart for the Water and Sewer Operating
Fund 8300 office of the Director provides leadership and oversight
in the operations for the Houston Public Works Department.
Houston Water produces and supplies portable drinking water throughout
the Harris County and portions of the surrounding counties.
Financial Management manages, monitors and controls department's financial
and accounting activities capital projects initiates and
manages the sale of surplus utility owned properties. It implements,
installs, configures, supports and maintains Houston Public
Works computer software, telecommunications and software
such as SCADA, WiMAX, Network and Security Systems
management support Branch provides support in the areas of records management,
fleet support and internal review. Now we have Customer
Account Services which reads maintains water sewer
meters, produces the bills, receives and processes invoice
payments, manages credit and collections processes and responds to
billing inquiries. Next slide, please.
The combined utility system total proposed budget is 1.6
billion for fiscal year 2023, of which
personnel accounts for 234,000,000 and non personnel budget
is one point rounded up to 1.4 billion. The nonpersonal
section consists of the following $583,000,000
is for debt service 285,000,000 water and wastewater
operations, 51 million transfer to Stormwater
and 300 million for the pay as you go for the cash funding for
the CIP. Next slide,
please.
Then this is the combined utility system revenues,
expenditures, and this sort of gives you a net overview.
And if you please note that in fiscal year 22 and fiscal year 23,
the combined utility system is showing a budgetary deficit,
which the combined utility system is intentionally spending down its
fund balance. Next slide,
please. That concludes the Houston
Public Works Budget presentation. We're open to any questions. Thank you
very much. We have a number of council members in queue. And first of all,
thank you for skinnying this down. When I saw 20
public speakers, I knew we had to do a little bit of an audible.
So thank you, directors. Appreciate that. Council Member Michael Kubosh.
Thank you very much. I noticed on page 40 you talked about that's
the first time I heard the word consent decree. Have we had any breaches
of the consent decree?
Would you mind repeating the question? The wastewater.
Have we had any breaches since we've actually signed the consent
decree? So we have continued to have some
sanitary sewer overflows that. Part of signing
the consent decree is an agreed plan
to invest and reduce those over time. There's a recognition
when you sign the consent decree that it's not going to magically stop.
So we have continued to have some, but we are doing better.
We are seeing significant reductions with the increased
cleaning and televising that is already happening. Let me ask you concerning
the defect. I get reports of defective water meters.
One of the biggest complaints I get is the fact that we have
water bills, that citizens are trying to contest
their water bills. Have we determined what
percentage of the water meters are defective and
what the citizens do? So let me
jump in real quick. It is very rare for an actual water meter
to be defective. What we are
seeing is the remote reader that attaches to the water meter.
They are 20 years old and they are dying every day.
And so what happens is, we have months where we estimate,
because we didn't get a good read, but the meters themselves,
it's very rare for one to be defective. Ways to test them.
Well, if the device that's attached to it, that's reading it is
defective, are getting old, then the citizen would consider that
a defective water meter because they see it as
all encapsulated. As one thing.
How do we buy fuel,
gasoline, gasoline, and diesel
and CNG? Do we purchase it in an
annual basis, or do we have contracts? How do we
get our fuel? So I'm going to defer that to fleet, as that
is not public works purchasing separately. It is a
citywide contract. Thank you very much. Put me back in the queue,
sir. Council Member Vice Chair Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair, and good morning to everyone. Thank you for the presentation.
My questions are regarding permitting from
a financial standpoint. What are some processes or
systems that we can put in place or that we have put
in place to streamline expedite, speed up
the permitting process.
So we recently gave a presentation to TTI about
some of the improvements and processes that are happening internally.
Some of the biggest things that we've done is
provide an opportunity for the same reviewer to review the plan set on
a subsequent submittal. But we've also
augmented our capacity by executing
outside contracts that allow us, when our capacity exceeds our personnel
resources, to use some of those outside resources.
We're still working to catch up and get on top
of it. We admit that we are longer than we need to be, but we
do believe that we have the tools in place to eat down the backlog and
keep up moving forward. So when you say that, you know that we're kind
of behind, but we're doing what we can to catch up,
are there benchmarks in place or a strategy
in place to show that, okay, we know we need to get here,
here's how we're going to do it. So yes, sir. And that's
part of what was presented at TTI just recently. I would
be happy it is available on the website. I'm council member.
We'll provide that information, but we'll be happy to provide you some
additional information on that. Okay? And can we jump to page 25
really quick,
Director? It might be good to get a date of that meeting if your staff
is able to help us with that for the Council member.
Everybody doesn't watch those.
Yes, sir. Page 25. Page 20.
Go ahead. Page 25. If we can pull it
up on the screen. There was a for
stormwater. We're showing a 4.8%
decrease change from variance
from fiscal year 22 to now. Can you further elaborate
on that?
Trying to find where you're looking at the 4.8 million. I'm seeing a 5.8 million
less transfer. I see the stormwater revenues, is that
what you're talking about? Not the top line. Right. So the, the revenues are decreasing
by 3.3 million. This is due to $5.8 million less
transfer needed from the combined utility system to cover operations
and maintenance cost. That's what it's due to. And it's offset
by an increase in transfer from 23 ten. So stormwater
gets its funding from two areas. One is Ddsr of 23 ten,
and the bulk of the funding comes from the combined utility system.
And so this year there was a lesser need and then a little bit of
an increase funding from the Ddsrf funds group. So it nets out
to about a 3.3 million decrease in the funding that was needed for
Saltwater. But there is adequate funding for it, in your opinion?
Yes, adequate funding. Absolutely. Thank you.
Before we go to council member Sally Alcorn, we've been
joined by council members Amy Peck, Tarsha Jackson,
Mary Anne Huffman, vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castex Tatum
and Chairman David Robinson. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you for your presentation.
In the Ddsrf drainage fee revenue, I noticed
that we budgeted last year like $113,000,000
in revenue. We ended up getting more than that, about 126 or 28
million, and then we're budgeting back down at 113. Is there a reason
that we had that increase last year and over what we thought? And why
aren't we expecting it? Again,
some of these revenues, it depends on projections,
and again, we look at it from a fund perspective. So you're budgeting more conservatively
on revenues. That's what we try to do. Just we don't want to overestimate.
Okay, thank you. And in the Ddsrf,
advalorum transferred from the general
fund was about 77 million, plan about 77 million.
We're advancing about 97 million to capital
projects. I'm assuming some of that's coming from from fund balance.
From from fund balance, yes. When we get the transfer from
the general fund to that fund, that is less what's paid
down in debt service. That's done before you get the transfer? That's correct. That is
debt service prior to do you know how much debt has been
paid down from Advalorum since Rebuild
Houston started? The amount of debt that we paid off so far has been
about and let me have that information here.
Let me bring that's
1.5 billion that's been paid, and we have about 905,000,000.
That's $1.5 billion in debt. And that is a
major thing because that's what let us borrow for
pension obligation bonds. I mean, that the reduction in debt was
a big part in letting us borrow more money. So that's an important feature
on the building Inspection fund. And that presentation was done in
November 4 of last year on permitting.
So we're due for an update, and Council Member Robinson and I will be
hosting an event on permitting. And put
me back in the queue. Council Member Michael Kubash.
Thank you very much.
Once again, the number of complaints that I receive
each week deal with either water problems,
either leaks, or the customer feels
overbuilt, and the other is permitting.
Permitting. The citizens just
shouldn't have to hire an expediter to get a
permit done. And I
don't know what your role is on trying to get
this permitting done properly, but I know that we passed,
during the Parker administration, right before she left,
we passed an ordinance that allowed the permit fees
to go into a separate fund. Is that still happening?
So the permitting fund
that we briefed today is a special revenue fund within the
general fund that was created during that time. So it is a subset of
the general fund, but it is somewhat firewalled
off in the sense that the fees generated by permit fees
stay in that fund and are used for the expenses in that fund.
Well, the whole purpose for permitting is for public safety and not for necessarily revenue
gathering. But I do want to say
that we definitely need some help there. How much
money did the Public Works apply for
ARPA funds or cares dollars from the federal government on COVID-19?
Separate that is, separate from this budget hearing,
and we're happy to provide that to you separately and offline.
We worked with the citywide processes for both ARPA and COVID
and within the city's priorities. We did receive funding
in both of those categories to support activities within the department,
but that is not included in this presentation
as we were directed. Well, I would sure like to have that sent to me.
Would you do that? Yes.
No, absolutely, yes. I mean, the City of Houston received
ARPA funds and it was subdivided into each and every
department within the city. I'm not sure what your allocation is that correct?
Yes, that is correct. Thank you,
Council Member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you,
Mayor Pro. Tim, you went through the presentation fairly quickly,
so can you clarify some points to me and just give me context for the
divisions that have a substantial budget but zero
FTE? So, for example, if we go
to page 27 stormwater Fund,
the Management Support Branch, it's 296,000,000,
but there's zero FTE. Can you just clarify why
it's a chargeback? Yes, I believe that's a citywide
chargeback that comes back to us that we pay.
And is that the same train of thought for all divisions
that might have substantial budget, certain C TOI processes that we pay
for that get charged back to us? Got it. Thank you much.
Follow up by Council Member Michael Kubosh. Can you
tell us where the city of Houston rates
in major cities as far as our water cost that we're
charging our citizens? Have you done a comparison with other cities
like Dallas or Fort Worth or the major Texas cities?
Yes, sir. Last year when we went through the rate study and
recommended updates to City Council, we had several charts that were direct
comparisons with other cities. We were at the bottom of the pile, and now we're
still towards the bottom of the pile. I'm glad to hear that. Thank you
very much for that. I think the citizens need to be aware of that because
when they get their water bills, I'm sure they don't feel that way. And the
bottom of the pile being good, as in we're cheaper.
Thank you very much. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you. Back on the building Inspection fund. And I know that
there are 26 additional FDES coming to
the permitting center over last year.
And that's good because in looking
at the performance measures, we're at 22% of
first reviews for commercial plans in 15 days, but our goal is
to get to 80%. So that's a pretty significant thing. I know we've done some
outsourcing. I know we've got some we have not done any
outsourcing. Not outsourcing. Sorry. Staff augmentation.
Very clear about that. Staff augmentation and
then hiring. And I'll ask
these in writing. I'd like to know specifically. I've got some charts there
where the Vacancies and make sure we're getting those 26 people to
the right places. Primarily, the complaints I
hear about on slow downs are in the office of City
Engineer, so traffic and Storm and to some degree,
planning. So that's where I'd want to see those
resources spent. But I'll have some additional questions in
writing, but just wanted to get that out there that I was happy to see
that there were 26. I think that we have had attrition of over
30 people. So 26 hopefully brings us back to address
the backlog and go to the future. Thank you. Yes. And make sure we upload
those to SharePoint, as you always. So thank you. Just a quick
follow up to Council Member Kubasha's. Questions related to permitting.
A few months ago, we did a supplement to hire we
hired a firm to supplement the existing employees.
Does that $89 million I'm looking on the expense side include
that, or is that separate? So it is
in the non personnel side of the expenses.
So it's not included in the 89 million I was looking at in the previous
page. Correct. I think I answered my own question.
It's not included. It's a supplement. You also mentioned consent
decree, stipulated penalties. How much do we pay in
stipulated penalties on consent decree? So the
first demand that we had, and I'd be recalling this from memory,
was for 1.2 million. 1.3 million.
And that was for a full year's worth.
We had budgeted about two and a half million when we originally laid this out.
And we're performing better and have lower estimates than that.
So less than 2 million a year. And it will continue to go
down, although the way that the agreement is
written, the stipulated penalties are a lot lower.
Now. When you get to year five and year eight and year ten,
they go up because that's the incentive for you to get the work done.
Got it. So we better get moving. Yes. So on
page slide 40, you had on
C US, 256,000,000 billion
dollar million dollar increase on the variance to
the budget you mentioned. It's pay as you go. Water Authority
contract Debt Is that the Northeast
water purification percentage debt in our percentage
of payment,
83 five. What is the increase?
You said pay go water is a
significant portion of it. Previously, we'd done about $70
million in Pego, but given the current environment, with the market
conditions, we increased that to 300 million. So it's an additional about 230,000,000.
That's a significant portion. But I think what you're talking about is 800,000,
which is a very small amount. That's increase for Water Authority
contractual debt that previously existed.
What bucket do we pay the Northeast water? Our share of the Northeast
water purification plant. It's part of the total debt services that I had mentioned previously
and included in the $583,000,000 on an annual basis.
Council member Tasha Jackson.
Thank you. Thank you, Director Haddock, for the presentation.
I have one question about the transportation and
drainage operation budget. Does that in any of that
include like a drainage maintenance plan
for neighborhoods that have the open ditches?
Yes, the operation side of that does include the maintenance of the
roadside ditches as part of the activities
within that fund. Okay. Because right now, I know the residents are
like the ditches that's within their neighborhoods. They are required
to maintenance their own drainages and
their ditches. And so one of the things we're trying to push is to get
Public Works to conduct that maintenance because that
contributes a lot of the flooding in these neighborhoods. And so I just
wanted to know, was that included? Yes, ma'am. Okay. Thank you,
staff from Council member Abby Cayman's office.
Good morning, everyone. Council Member Cayman first wants to thank
Public Works and the entire team and the Director, of course, for your
leadership and all the work that you guys are doing day in and
day out. There are too many people to think individually right now,
but we recognize not only the budgetary challenges,
but the additional challenge that COVID presented. I know you didn't
go through them, but the list is in the appendix
should be commended. We have a few questions that we will also share and submit
through the SharePoint. But she noticed some
divisions in Red, and that
Council Member came in, has passed on a budget amendment last year
that will possibly help inspections and bring in additional revenue.
Flagging that to see where in the process that is.
Again, we will communicate that question via SharePoint.
The question that Council Member Cayman is asking of each department is due to
the budgetary constraints, including the revenue cap, what needs exist
that we are not able to address through this year's budget?
That's a big question. So within the activities that we have
defined for us, we believe that we have adequate funding to address
if we want to add activities citywide, that's where we begin to
run into challenges. I know there's some requests for additional maintenance
in some areas that we see,
particularly in the storm drainage system. We also see it in our sidewalks.
And so our challenges would be those. But I would
also remind everybody that in street and drainage, in our transportation
and drainage operations, we are limited to 25%
that can be spent on O and M by Ddsrf, by the
charter amendment.
And we are at that 25% with the activities
we have. So additional funding wouldn't necessarily even be available
for those activities. Council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you. Just to follow up on that, can you share more about the
capital improvement projects that have been scheduled but not funded?
Because I know we have significant number of capital improvements that
are due to neighborhoods. So in context of having adequate funding,
but also the caveat of that 25%. Could you elaborate on that?
Well, so the capital improvements are not with that 25%
cap. And so the funding that we have available,
we've seen a significant increase in the estimated cost
of those projects. And so everybody's still in
line. It takes longer to serve the line. And so because
of the increased cost, in some cases, the decreased funding
we have seen because of revenue cap less transfer than
we had originally projected on the advilorum side, and that's really
what has extended out. We've also seen a decrease in metro
sales tax revenue that has been transferred as well.
So it is really a struggle. But we
have those projects developed enough to seek the federal funding
that should become available through the infrastructure bill and the
IJA. So we are actively matching
projects to programs as we see the buckets become
available to move those forward, with a big emphasis
on looking for funding those capital projects in our
communities that have historically been underinvested.
And there's no way to skip the line. I'm just asking, can we skip the
line? No.
Last question from council members is Council Member David Robinson.
Thank you, Chair and Director. Thanks for your presentation. I know you've covered a lot
of territory and picking up a little bit where my colleague Tiffany
Thomas just went with Deferred CIP projects and
some of what our chair has inquired about with the biggest ticket items
on water and sewer and the general purpose combined
utility programs. I wanted to get some territory
on the real bottom of that. I know you and I have talked about the
expenditures going to the accessibility program that Director
Casares has taken on, as well as some of what you've described today with
TranStar and other programs. So from the large
budget items to the small, I wonder if you could just take a second to
narrate some of your concerns about the changes
in the budget this year, what we might be looking at, and anything
that we can help you with. I don't know that I would use concerns.
I would say that we definitely have some opportunities to look
back at our activities and make sure that everything that we're
putting our energy effort resources to is the highest priority for the
city. And so as we look at our biggest ones,
our water and wastewater, obviously we're going to be focused on the
resilience and sustainability of the existing systems
while also allowing for that future growth and redevelopment.
And if you bring that through water wastewater, that also includes
street and storm. But on the permitting side, this will
be the year that we really focus on moving towards the
2021 building codes. And so we're going to be really focused on
that forward leaning. What can we do to make sure that we are setting things
in place that administrations after this
one where I'm sitting,
are primed for the future?
Yes, and as you and I have spoken about with that on the queue of
things that we're going to take on, whether that's within a special called meeting
in the June meeting of the TTI committee or as soon as
we can get to it after July 1,
we're going to take that on pending the administration's approval.
So thank you very much, Director. Thank you, Chair.
We'll now move to the public comment section. There are six virtual
public speakers and we have a total of 20
public speakers on the list. Please, when I announce your name,
please hit star six to unmute because we will have to go rapidly.
Our first speaker is Mr. Doug Smith. 1 minute.
Each speaker has 1 minute.
Doug Smith.
Mr. Tom Thompson. Star Six. Mr.
Thompson?
Yes. Can you hear me? Is this Mr.
Thompson? That's Doug. Yes, go ahead.
Who do we have? Do we have Tom Thompson?
And this is Doug Smith as well.
Do we have Mr. Thompson?
Yes, go ahead. Do you hear me? Yes, sir, we can.
Okay, thank you.
Do you want Doug to go first? Yes, please.
Mr. Thompson, we're waiting.
My comments very brief. I just want to say I
am encouraged to see the increase in funding proposed
for street maintenance in the transportation and drainage operations
budget, but strong alert to the city
to allocate sufficient funding to ensure that our bike lanes
are regularly cleaned and maintained, ensuring that this
critical transportation in
which the city and its partners have already made and committed a significant
investment, can continue to be used, thereby increasing
safety and accessibility for all transportation modes.
Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Thompson. Go ahead, Mr.
Smith. Good morning. I have
two quick comments. First of all, congratulations to the Department.
If you look at page 958 of the report,
their performance statistics with the Metro funds is fantastic.
It's the best of any department that I've seen, and they deserve
credit for that. And I'd like to ask one question. We provide
water to entities outside the city. This is a valuable commodity
and getting more valuable every day. Can we charge premium
rates to those users to recognize that value
and give Houston citizens a break in their bills?
Unfortunately, I've asked that question many times, and the answer to that
is no, we cannot. Why?
We're required by state.
Okay, that answers it. Thank you.
Next speaker is Mr. That's all,
Joseph. Katufro.
Good morning. Can you hear me okay? Yes, sir. Thank you. Sorry for butchering your
name. It's all right. Happens every day.
Good morning. My name is Joe Kutrufo, and I'm the Executive Director of Bike Houston,
a nonprofit organization working to transform Houston into a city where
anyone can get around safely and easily by bike.
Like Mr. Thompson, I'm here to express support for the Houston
Bikeways Maintenance program. Houston's bike network
is critical transportation infrastructure and it's time to start maintaining
it as such. And it's no secret to anyone, including some people in this
room who ride bikes around our city that are protected by leaves,
litter, broken glass. I even came across the aftermath of
car crash and found the whole front end of a Honda in the bike lane
one time. This is the number one complaint that Bike Houston hears about from people
who ride bikes and in fact, some folks in this room. Council members
Alcorn Robinson, we saw the debris piling up in the WA and
Commonwealth bike lanes. Council member Pollard, you may remember the garbage we saw
in the new bike lanes on Hillcroft. Council member Cesneros knows all too
well about the debris in the bike lanes on Hardy Street. And Council member Kubosh
could spend a lot less on repairs at Blue Line Bike Lab if our bikeways
were better maintained. And nobody likes a flat tire, of course. But when we fail
to clear debris out of our bikeways, we create a safety hazard too. Because when
the lanes are full of debris, people opt to ride outside of the bike lanes,
entirely defeating the purpose of the bike lanes. We've invested so much
in building Houston's amazing bike network. And we're going to celebrate
these investments on Friday at the City's Bike to Work Day. But we can't stop
at just building the lanes. We have to do the fiscally responsible thing and
maintain them too. Our bike network. Mr. Katrufo,
I'll let you go longer than a minute. Can you wrap it up in 5
seconds? I do. Friday. We have to make sure it's
useful and safe. And if we're serious about being a multimodal city where people
have real transportation options other than driving, we need to make sure the bike
lanes are useful and safe. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Mr. Kurtrufo. Just to make sure we don't have
Jason Oliver, Aris Brown or Vicky Martin on virtually.
And you are? Okay. Jason,
come on. We'll go through the list. Next we
have Saba Blanding no,
we'll call you in a minute.
Yes, sir. 1 minute. Just a reminder. Got it? Yes, sir.
Hi. I'm Jason Oliver. I live in District G.
Few questions I'm interested in. Oh perfect. That's helpful.
Thank you.
So I was tall too, so this works. Well,
I see that you all completed 74 council district service from
projects, which is great. People often mention how long it takes to implement
CDSF projects. I'm interested in what can we do to
speed up the implementation. Kind of going along with what Council member
Thomas said. And I'm also interested on page 29, if you
can explain how much is being transferred through
these 380 agreements specifically and then to which entities
are receiving those which entities are receiving those funds.
Thank you.
Hold on 1 second.
Any comments to
answer the previous question for a 380 agreement is about 4.1 million.
4.1. Yes. Okay, thank you.
Debt service. Correct. Got it.
You are Saba Blanding? Yes. Okay.
Hi, I'm saba Blanding District I i had two questions
over the past seven years. I noticed that your department has seen fluctuations
in your budget for year to year, increasing as much as 9.8%
and decreasing as much as 19%. How have
these annual fluctuations impacted your department's ability to
plan for and provide adequate services to meet the needs of the
city of Houston? I thought it was really interesting how much it fluctuated.
And secondly, on slide 14, you said that more infrastructure is
degrading due to deferred, maintenance and insufficient
reinvestment. What type of investment do you need to
see from the city of Houston in order for your department to
address Houston's infrastructure needs in a timely manner?
So fluctuation in budget and then the second
part yeah, it just goes back to so some of
this fluctuation in budget over previous years has actually been rollover
of capital equipment. Our vehicles are replacing our
dump trucks. Very large expenditures that transfer from year to year in the
operations budget. On the capital investment side, what we're seeing
is actually the result of decades of underinvestment
that we can't maintain to keep it in useful life when
something's 50, 60, 70 years old. And so that statement is really
referring to the fact that we have increased build. Use of
forward is increasing the reinvestment and reconstruction.
But there are things that are because every year we go
along, things are continuing to age that continue to get
beyond that. The water and wastewater system, the water rate study that we did last
year will have a significant reinvestment in the water and wastewater system
as a result of those rates.
Thank you. Diane Crest.
Diane Cress.
Doug, turn your camera off. We love you, but we don't love
you that much. Diane Cress.
Diane Cress.
Brown. Doris Brown.
Okay, keep going.
Becky Seal. I'm sorry. You, miss Brown.
My apologies. Come on forward. We'll have Ms.
Doris Brown followed missed by Miss Becky Seal.
My name is Doris Brown, and I'd like to address the historic disinvestment
in our bipartisan neighborhoods. For years,
we have lived with the threat of flooding.
It has come to the point to where we are anxious when it start to
rain. Excuse me?
It has come to the point when we get anxious and we get varied.
It's kind of like post traumatic distress.
When it rains, we get anxious. We get scared because
we know that our streets are going to hold water.
We have been historically disinvested and
disenfranchised. We would like to have an amendment for
the public works to have more money so they could do something about the flooding
in our bipartisan neighborhoods. Not only that, we want
to address the worst first. We would like for someone to come
out to our neighborhoods and start doing some work that alleviate
the flooding that's going on.
I'll give you another couple of seconds. Could you define your
neighborhood? My neighborhood is City
Gas Lakewood. The northeast neighborhood. Got it. District B,
we have 88% of open dish
drainage, and we just need
some help out there. We need some infrastructure because the infrastructure is antiquated,
right? Yes. We're the worst first.
Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you. Yes, ma'am. Ms. Brown.
Ms. Brown. Ms. Brown. Thank council Member Jackson. Thank you,
Ms. Brown, for coming in and for your group,
for all the work that you guys been doing in the district
to make sure that we get the resources and get the projects we
need to mitigate the flooding within District B.
The neighborhoods are the Northeast, Houston. You have cashmere? Garden,
Fifth Ward Acres Homes. And so these are neighborhoods that's
hit hard every flood. 88% of the
open ditches are in our district. That was a ditch study conducted
back in 2014 out of the Hurricane Ike
Disaster Recovery Round $2 that indicated that we needed
some investment within our neighborhoods. And so I assure you that
it's my priority. I will be submitting amendment to make sure that
we get the resources, some dollars allocated
for ditch maintenance, because if our ditches are not and our drainages are
not maintenance, that's what causes a lot of the flooding. And we can't
depend on seniors to do something that
we should be doing. We were doing it at one point. That changed
in 2001. And so I'm going to make
sure that we try to get a drainage schedule maintenance regularly within
our district. So thank you all for your advocacy. Thank you.
Thank you. Ms. Becky Seal.
Morning. Hey, good morning.
I'm Becky Seal with the Northeast Action Collective. And Doris and
all these people talking that packet we just passed out to you kind of,
like, elaborates a bit on why we're working with Tarsha to do this
budget amendment and really the details of what we're talking about.
So I heard you guys say that there is money for
drainage maintenance right now, and we'd like to know if that's different than
previous years, because the maintenance to this point really
is not matching the need at all. And if so
or regardless, where can the public see a schedule so that we can keep
public works accountable to that? So let me ask this question.
So we're dealing with general fund right now. I think that's dealing
with capital improvement project dollars. So two different things.
We will attack CIP probably next month or
so. So if an amendment comes forward within the general fund,
there has to be a correspondent debit that
you take away from it and a funding source that's identified. And Council Member Jackson
will probably submit that as well with her amendment.
But we will take up CIP. Am I correct in that?
Well, it's both. So there is an O and M
component to this. And I do want to clarify,
and I hope you will acknowledge that Veronica Davis and her team
have been very actively engaged with this community over the last year
and have worked with you to identify specific locations.
We have actually done surveys of the roadside ditches throughout
the area, and we've identified, I believe, 25 different projects
that we'll be doing over the next 18 months in that area that
are in our budget that are funded to be done.
And so I want to make sure that it's clear that we have
responded to, that we are actively but that's
just the first step. Those are the ones that you all have identified
that, you know, we're looking at the entire
area out there and working to identify those improvements. So we've
also done the maintenance through the entire area of
everything that has been identified to us. And there's a
difference between true maintenance, where it's actually
going out, and removing silt and soil and things in those ditches and restoring
culverts versus day to day, like,
I take care of my house, which is making sure
that the litter is not getting there, and things of that nature throughout
the city. What we ask people to do is that
light level maintenance, not that heavy maintenance
that we do. So we've been working with Veronica
Davis a lot. Right. And what she's told us is that the
money that they have to do proactive maintenance is not nearly enough,
that it's 500 miles of open ditch drainage throughout the entire city
per year. And she has said, unless we have more money put aside
for this, we cannot do the maintenance required. And we don't
think that the only ditches that should be maintained is from a group
of us who semi professionally come to city council
and have to put our entire lives into identifying ditches.
Yes, there's been a massive improvement, and it's been amazing to work
with Veronica Davis. We've really liked working with her and appreciated the
response. But we think that there has to be a shift from
that pattern to being more proactive. And she specifically has said the
only way that's possible is if there's more money specifically put for
that. Yes. And Miss Seal, if you want
to look up the CIP map that we have,
it can be found@buildhoustonforward.org. And you'll
see the CIP. Yeah, we've looked at it a lot. But the CIP projects is
not what we're talking about. We're not talking there are two buckets of
projects. One is general fund and one in CIP. So we'll
get to CIP, but your general fund. Okay.
But in either one, you can't see what the actual money for
ditch maintenance is. And we've scoured the Internet. If it's
out there, please send it to us. We're trying to see if there's money
in one of those overall city
line in the CIP budget that's going to ditch maintenance.
What does that mean? And then in the general fund, same thing. So that we
can if it's already happening spectacular,
we just want to see it and understand. Council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you. In addition to the budget amendment
your council member is going to offer, last year council Member Peck,
during budget last year authored an amendment for council
members to leverage council district service funds
to maintain open ditches in our district. And I know
she's had some successes with that. So in addition to
that, your council member can couple the work around the timeline and the
schedule that you're requesting, but then also leveraging some of the dollars
she has locally to make sure that the funding
that TDO is limited. To do that, the council
office can support. That's been great, and you talk
too, but Ms. Jackson has done a lot with that.
But that statistic Doris pointed out, 88% of open ditch
maintenance is in non white
and poor neighborhoods, basically. So every city district having
some money to put to that doesn't nearly address the problem.
It's an unequal problem. So there has to be what
I'm clarifying is that you have additional method.
So it's and in both. So in addition to what's showing up in the general
fund and the budget amendment for a timeline, she actually all of
us have dollars available to support that where TDO
is limited. So it's and in both. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, Miss Sale. Next, we have Ms. Carolyn Addison
Rivera.
Good morning. What you see here are recent
pictures of the ditches that
we live in and the contamination that
we deal with with water and our
land. The first thing I want to do is say thank you.
Okay. The first thing I want thank you, sir.
Yes, ma'am. The first thing I want to do is say
thank you to the city council and
to let you know that we need you.
We cannot. This is recent. If you can see this,
this is what we live with every day.
I have been calling Veronica
Davis and the rest of since 2014,
pleading for help. I've lived in that community
over 40 years. When I moved
there, there was regular maintenance.
We had no flooding. My children could play.
This was not in our community.
This is reason. Just yesterday,
I called and the guy come out,
asked me, what do I want him to do? They dig
ditches. Well water. Just stand. Do you hear
me? It just stand. Thank you. Thank you.
Ms. Addison Rivera. Thank you. And thank you very
much. We need you. We can't do it without you.
This is it reason. Thank you,
ma'am. Appreciate it. Leah Johnson.
Leah Johnson.
Benjamin Broadway.
Thank American.
Mr. Broadway. Morning, sir.
There you go. We're good. Okay. Thank you.
I'm going to get straight to the point. In the Northeast,
we need sewage and
runoff. Help our kids stand
in water when they're waiting for the school bus.
Do your kids wait and stand in water? They get to school soaking
wet. We need flood help
in our area. We need the covered ditches.
Three, one, one is a joke to me
because when I call for help, they have
us register. Every year, every time we move, when the
disabled and visually impaired people relocate,
they ask us to register. I register. I've never
gotten one call from three one one to say,
hello. Mr. Broadway. Are you okay? Do you need to evacuate?
My family has had to come in high water vehicles to
come and get me from my home. So please,
with your help help. District B, I'm in Lakewood.
I'm one of many disabled people that need the help.
Thank you, Mr. Broadway, would you like a couple of seconds of my time to
complete your statement? Yes.
If there's any way we can try and make the system
better, because every time we call
with even simple things of loose
animals because I can't walk to my mailbox without trying
to get attacked by a dog,
and the flooding issues, here I am facing
another hurricane season. I'm terrified from
a small rain. I don't know if my area is
going to flood because the covered ditches, they have
so much in them. Thank you. Council member Tasha Jackson. I just
wanted to thank them for coming in and sharing their concerns.
And then also just to piggyback on what Director Haddock did
say about the SWAT projects slated for the area,
and we doing the H and H studies. I think we just completed the
H and H studies to actually show why these particular neighborhoods
are draining. I mean, it's true that there has been no investment,
why these neighborhoods are flooding. There has been no investment. And now we are
getting the studies to identify why these neighborhoods are flooding. And then
the next round is the fixing, the mitigating, these flooding.
I mean, we have train tracks. We're always talking about the trains that's
contributing to a lot of the flooding. So I just want to assure you that
there has been a lot of movement and we're doing a lot of work.
We had a lot of projects slated for the district to address the flooding.
But then also, we do need a ditch maintenance
schedule. So I'm with you on that. And, of course, Director Haddock said there's
resources already in this budget for that. And so I'm
going to have further conversations just to identify what is the amount, how much
do it cost. If I have to use some of my district service funds,
I will use some of my district service funds, but I have to use for
parks and the illegal dumping and all these other things. So a million
dollars only goes so far. So I want to try to work with the departments
and see if we can find resources to move some of these projects. So thank
you again for coming. Thank you. Thank you, Chair, and thank you,
sir, for coming. This question is for the Public Works Director. So the
document they provided, it said prior to 2001,
we did regular maintenance. The city did regular maintenance of
roadside ditches. And now
we just go based on three one on complaints.
Did the city ever have a policy where we regularly maintained,
I'll be honest with you, council Member, I do not know the answer to that
question. I'm going to have to get with and Eric Dargan joined
the city in 2002. I joined in 2005.
I'm unaware of that. But I also do know that
there were a lot of things that in the late ninety s and early
2000s, because of the limitations on
the general fund, which at the time was in the general fund,
were not able to continue forward. So I do not know the answer to that
question because I've always been under the impression we did more major
regrading and things like that on a regular schedule. But the maintenance
itself, like the mowing, I mean, these pictures are way more
than just mowing needed. I mean, that's a different situation.
But that was the property owner's responsibility. Thank you.
Malberth Moses.
Good morning.
I don't understand why I'm have to come up here and fight for what's
supposed to be our rights in the first place.
I moved in my neighborhood over 50
years ago and it was predominantly white neighborhood.
I couldn't even go outside the plate till you choose because being
attacked. But they had a regular schedule
of keeping up the ditch maintenance, picking up the
heavy trash. But then as the neighborhood began
to grow more black
and brown, all of a sudden this stopped.
And I don't see why all stopped all of
a sudden. Why we just got took off the schedule
altogether. I haven't seen anybody come in that neighborhood in
over 20 years to clean the ditches. And that's
ridiculous because we deserve that, right?
So can somebody answer that question? Why do
I have to come up here and fight for a right that I already deserve?
Thank you, Mr. Moses. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
I'm sorry. Thank you.
I'm sorry. Vice chair, Ed Pollard.
Thank you sir, for coming in. Your comment,
this is for public Works. When you all are going out and identifying
projects and infrastructure needs for
improvements to the drainage, or is there
some type of list
that you all have put together to
be able to understand what are the drainage and infrastructure
needs for that particular area? Has that been
shared to the public? Do we have a cost estimate for
some of those improvements so that we as council can be better abreast
on what could be done to alleviate
some of these issues? That the community I will interject.
Each district gets $2 million in SWAT projects designated
by their council members. I know we do that. And every other district receives
2 million in SWAT projects. I'm not sure where your neighbor is on the District
B project list, but we do have the ability to do that what
I'm speaking of is just general, not swap
projects because those are smaller, like 2 million a year projects.
What I'm saying is like an overall high level view of
infrastructure needs when it pertains to drainage
and maintenance for an area like District B that has a lot of open ditches.
So I may ask Veronica to come up and join us,
but it's been in the last
decade through this administration that we've actually gone out
and surveyed Ditches Citywide to have an idea on what the
capacity of those ditches are. And we're currently
working on a condition assessment for Ditches Citywide,
which would give us more of that answer. We did have from the late
90s, early two thousand s, a capacity assessment
of the Pipe Systems Citywide. And so this is
that data driving. And so to be
more proactive, you have to have that citywide data.
In lieu of having that data. We did rely a
lot on the three one one reports, and that's what we're working with the
council member right now. When would the
data be available for you all to do an assessment?
Good morning, everyone. Well, good afternoon at this point. So.
Veronica Davis, director of Transportation and Drainage operations in Houston
Public Works. So one, we're working on our stormwater master
plan. So the city up until now has never had a full
master plan. So currently, right now,
we should be going to a notice to proceed very soon.
And so there'll be a couple of components with that. So part of it will
be doing an H and H hydraulics analysis
for the city to be able to understand these needs,
and then two, to be able to think about what is the full
need that we have for the city. We have have other plans that
have been done that we will pull into this process to help inform
some of that. And I also want to clarify what we do generally,
we do rely on three one one right now for digit maintenance.
And so we do send our digital maintenance crews out to do the regrading to
do the desilting. Once it is beyond the ability of our
internal crews to do, we do refer it to either SWAT,
which we work with the council members on. We also have the local drainage program.
And so we have been working with the Northeast Action Collective.
We have projects right now that are indesigned. We do our design in house.
So we are currently working on projects that are indesigned. And in the
new fiscal year, we'll be going to construction to address some of the
concerns that have been brought up by the collective.
Thank you, Ms. Davis. Thank you, Mr. Moses.
Council Member David Robinson. I'm sorry, this one was with Mr.
Moses in mind, but basically a comment wanting
to thank the Northeast Action Collective for being here.
I think in addition to what we just heard from Ms. Davis and the director.
I think there are some really positive trends.
This is slow coming. And your patience and observations in
the neighborhood, we understand why that's a grievance,
why that's not fair and not right and not satisfactory.
So I think moving forward, what we've heard today are some of the very
progressive actions that are being taken. They need to happen faster,
in my opinion. And part of what we're doing together,
with your input, with your group and with some of the
tools that the Director mentioned is detect problems sooner,
work on them more proactively, with an inventory of
those ditches, those pipes, and where we can be
more effective and more fair, more equitable with our dollars.
And working across this huge city, But I think the
literature that you all have brought today is really well done.
It's compelling, it's instructive, and it
points a path to where the worst first can be prioritized.
So I want to salute you, Mr. Moses, and thank you for coming today.
Thank you. James Burford.
James Burford. Got you.
Sandra Edwards.
Good morning, everybody.
I'm not going to even hold you all along because everything I want to say
has been said, has been said already.
This is just a map of the community in the neighborhood. I'm from I'm from
two six. Okay, the council closed and all that good stuff. Okay, I just
want to say one thing. You all need to put first things first.
I know you all been hearing all this and I know you're tired of hearing
all this because we're tired of saying it, but can you all put first things
first? We didn't showed you the proof. That what we need. It's not like we're
asking for it because this is just we feel we better. They think they better
because they get everything that needs to come their way. For you to come to
our area, can you put first things first? Come to our area, do some cleanup,
clean some drainages. Maybe we won't flood so much and
stop these people from going against us,
our communities, and bringing in stuff that's going to make us flood,
stopping up our drainages and everything. Just do the
right thing for once. That's all I got to say. Do something right for a
change. Thank you. Julia arduna.
Julia Arduna.
Anil Kapoor.
Okay, thank you, council people, for having us
come in today to speak and giving us a chance to speak.
Before I talk, I do want to express my gratitude to
Veronica Davis and her department. In a little less than a
year, her and her office have been way more impactful
for our neighborhood and our collective and
the residents that have been there for over 20 years than any
of the previous people in her position.
Also want to thank Tasha Jackson for being open and working
with us as well and being accessible.
I just want to read this prepared statement.
We would love for the city council to amend a public
works budget to include a pilot program for drainage maintenance
in district B. Specifically, it is one of the most flood prone areas
and has very high concentrations of BIPOC and LMI
people, as well as public housing. Open ditch drainage is an example of separate
and unequal that leaves our communities vulnerable.
It's essential that we invest before the next hurricane and disaster.
Our seal thank you. Supposed to rise 18 inches. Thank you, sir.
Thank you. Appreciate it. David espinoza.
Have Mr. Espinoza, then followed by Mr. Butler, and that will conclude
the public speakers. Mr. Espinoza.
Good afternoon. My name is David. I'm from
district b. I want to say that
I used to be in just about the same predicament as my
colleagues in the NAC.
About a half a year ago, there was some development
right along little York and epson road.
And around the same time, there was also commercial development.
There was a couple of fast food places going up.
And at the same time, there was a road maintenance,
which came along with ditch maintenance.
And my family saw a dramatic improvement from
the flooding we got we used to have we couldn't get out of
our neighborhood when it when it was flooded real bad. But that's proof
that ditch maintenance widening ditches, making them deeper,
cleaning them out, it's not regular, but we
do our best to keep our trash out, me and
my neighbors, and so far,
we've been doing good so far, and I want to see that happening
throughout the northeast with my fellow
members, to see them live better. Thank you, Mr.
Espinoza. Thank you,
Mr. Butler.
You're the last one we can say good morning to, so we will. Good morning.
Good afternoon. My name
is Broderick Butler, and I'm a resident of district b.
Those are my neighbors, and our message is pretty consistent.
Along with getting things done faster, we'd like for things to be done properly
and consistently. Council member Robinson,
with all due respect, this is the first time I'm hearing these
staff names, and I've long since wanted the senior
management to come to our district and talk to
people on their level about a problem that you've
heard from multiple people over a period of
decades. So my questions directed to the director
are, who makes the decision where money is
spent in their department in regards to our district and
infrastructure projects? I also want to know, again this question
of scheduling. There are people that have lived in this community their entire
lives, and they've seen things go away. They're not lying to
you. Lastly, there's a water treatment plant. There's still
a disconnect there's a water treatment plant that was created in the
northeast. No one knows it even exists that lives in the
northeast. So I would say to you,
this department, while it has done a lot of good for
us, we need some more reaching out to
this community to talk about solving the problems
that exist. Thank you. Thank you. And I have some additional
questions that I'd like to submit in writing.
We will put those into SharePoint. That concludes the
Houston Public Works Budget workshop. Thank you,
Director Haddock. Thank you,
Director Salanki. Appreciate your insight.